here Gordon is facing uh Nikki Rod
former training Pana and
um again the intention here is this has
to be put in the context that Gordon
will be fighting the greatest ACC
Grappler of all time in a few hours
after this so what we're looking for is
a uh a quick
resolution
um still the shortest possible match now
there's a complicating Factor here Nikki
Rod was a wrestler before he was a jiu
jitsu player
on paper
the way his route to win is via
wrestling is not going to be able to
um
submit Gordon Ryan and he's not going to
be able to pass his guard so he has to
win by wrestling
in the 80cc finals you cannot set the
guard so the the approach that Gordon
used earlier that we saw on video cannot
be used in the finals Gordon must
wrestle his opponent
so
on the way out
uh Gordon and I were talking and we'd
had discussions obviously during the
camp what's the appropriate thing to do
here
and there had been some
matches earlier in the event where it
was becoming obvious that stalling
was being heavily punished by referees
so
I said to Gordon on the way out just
give him your leg
let him take you down because in the
first 10 minutes of the finals takedowns
don't score anything well there are no
there are no means of scoring the first
10 minutes but you can't set the guard
that will be that will award you a
negative point so I said just let Nikki
Royal take you down and he's like Nikki
Rod's not going to take the bait and I
said if he doesn't they'll call him for
stalling
and so
and and then Craig Jones also commented
after the fact is I don't know why Nikki
took the beat
um so if we see the start of the match
you see Gordon comes out and offers her
leg now it's not that you know Nikki
Wright is smart he knows what's
happening here and uh what's he going to
do store for 10 minutes and get like
five restoring calls put against them so
Gordon gives them the takedown that way
they go to the ground immediately with
no effort and the match now favors
Gordon because Gordon is
uh significantly more skilled on the
ground
um
the question is how can we make this
match as short as possible and as is so
often the case the answer comes back to
legs
so uh for people just listening to this
Gordon is in an open guard and nicarad
appears to be trying to keep his hips
away from Gordon's legs yes the big
Nikki Rod knows there's a danger here so
he's elected to go to his knees that
will set up his favorite body lock
passes and it will in some ways mitigate
some of the dangers associated with leg
logs so Gordon's whole thing is how am I
going to get my body weight underneath
them here's a choice between linear
entries where he enters between his
opponent's knees and circular entries
where he inverts and Spins underneath
his opponent to get under a center of
gravity is there a way for somebody to
try to get a body lock without giving
Gordon an opportunity to get under under
them uh well the body lock is an
excellent way to shut down leg lock
entries if you can get to the body lock
but you can see Gordon's very very
disciplined with his elbow and knee
position elbows and knees are working in
a position where it's very very hard for
his opponent to access his waste
foreign
either across the hip or in front of the
shoulder sorry his knee is either in
front of the shoulder or in front of the
hip and we're one minute into the match
and just if I were to look at the video
player here it appears that the match is
over soon so uh
so I guess Nicki Wright is facing this I
need to get close in order to do the uh
the body lock and the closer you get the
more danger there is
uh to let Gordon get uh under you and
get the leg control
foreign
to get close here Gordon's going to try
and get his head underneath this
opponent make a circular entry into the
legs
he's clearing his opponent's head out of
the way by faking the arm drag on the
far side the first move that he used
against his uh first opponent earlier in
the tournament and there's the leg spins
underneath it
go circular rotates through gets his
body weight underneath his opponent okay
now he's going to trip him down to the
mat now uh I believe Nigeria tries to
pull out his foot here
and Craig also said that nicarad has
gotten used to being able to pull that
foot out from anybody and that he was
very surprised at the grip
that that Gordon was able to actually
hold on
so I just want to comment I'm I'm just
I'm just parroting commentary um if you
look at what's happening here from the
internet uh just if you just freeze it
you'll see that Gordon like any good leg
Locker will always treat his opponent's
foot like a knot at the end of the Rope
just as you slide down a rope if there's
a knot at the end your hand will catch
yeah so too with the human leg
when they go to extract by pulling you
just keep your fist is close to your
shoulder shoulder as possible and narrow
the Gap the foot will always catch the
failure that many people have is they
let their hand drift away from their own
shoulder and so there's room for the
foot to extract but you'll see Gordon's
extremely disciplined with thumb close
to his own shoulder which creates a
situation that's very very hard just to
simply pull your foot out you're you're
focusing on the knot of the foot yeah
also it's very early in the match
there's very little sweat both athletes
are still pretty dry
now Gordon has to climb the leg
and now he's already captured his
opponent's shoelace there's the heel
exposure coming up Nicky Wright already
knows things are getting bad
and there's the win actually the comment
I made I guess was from a little bit
earlier there was an earlier time where
Nikki while I was trying to pull out the
foot and the Gordon's able to hold on to
the knot
um which which is interesting
now that was uh
a brilliant day's work by Gordon Ryan he
said two matches against opponents
considerably bigger and stronger than
himself
and uh the time of the two matches can
be measured in
I think less than two minutes so he's
he's done what he's set out to do no
injuries no exhaustion he's beaten four
guys back to back all of whom are
excellent athletes with minimal energy
expenditure and he's ready to go on to
his super fight